you know anytime that you said people
want to I'm sure you've asked been asked
this question a million times but for me
it's sort of unique uh the whole Andrew
tapate thing you've been labeled the
female Andrew Tate right so I actually
personally think it's sort of a
convenient analogy it's easy he stands
for one thing all right there's the
woman that does this you know I don't
see many similarities between you and
Andrew Tate literally other than maybe
the traditional role of a woman um so
you know Andrew Tate
badass six I mean you're all pretty tall
I'll give you that you know 6'2 kickbox
Champion multi-millionaire driving
Bugattis hanging out with hot chicks you
know body count I'm like the cheapest
person ever yeah he's balling out you
know he's spending money you know your
your body count I assume is low uh
you're you're you're not exactly driving
Bugattis you're you're kind of that um
you're not exactly fighting people I
don't I don't know if you've ever been
in a physical altercation or at least
recent I actually I'm learning I'm
learning to box now you know to protect
yourself so I just think that it's a
convenient analogy I get it I've also
interviewed him handful of times I think
he's the man you know how I feel about
him but uh so do you think uh why do you
think you've earned this nickname and uh
do do you like it do you do do you find
some contentiousness with it what are
your thoughts well I I like I'm a fan of
Andrew Tate so I mean I take it as a
compliment I I don't think I think if
you're more like involv like you know
more about the space you're familiar
with the content you would see where we
differ like I I don't I've never heard
him say women shouldn't vote you know I
think that's more of a me thing so
you're more Hardline on women than
Andrew Tate probably yeah yeah you're
the more rightwing Andrew yeah yeah like
I think I'm further than him I was like
I don't know I was like beat Andrew I
was like I don't even know how he feels
about this comparison he's like I think
women should vote I swear where else do
you think you guys differ um me and
Andrew Tate
um
H um I don't really know I most things I
agree with him on but I I would say I've
never heard him say women shouldn't vote
um I I would argue that marriage is a
bad deal for men in 2023 um and I've
heard him kind of flip-flop on that love
that I've heard him go back and forth so
interesing that you use the word
flip-flop but you know I would say that
Andrew Tate since we've ended up
speaking with him almost 2 years ago
till today everything that's happened
with him is that he's evolved his
opinions have changed his lifestyle has
changed what the circumstances dealing
with yeah but that's my point though
like initially maybe we might have
agreed but now it's like I don't know if
we do so it's fair to say that he's
evolved yeah right so look into the
future two years down the road let's say
you've been making content for a few
years now blew up what do you think that
you're most likely to evolve on
ideologically HM
I don't know it's hard to predict the
future I don't
know
um meaning how about this are there some
stances like the women can't vote the
women are Dumber the women are that
you're like you know what they could be
an argument made that no because I've
always said there's exceptions like I've
always I've always they never clip this
part but I'll always say there is
exceptions like you're telling me aanka
Trump is not better than at business
than the average man a woman raised by
the president you know there's always
been exceptions in history um there's
always been high IQ women but they don't
make the rule and I think generally um
the statements like that you're talking
about now no I think I don't see those
pry firm on where you're at yeah yeah
but you know I'll always change my mind
with new information and I really would
like to find something that women are
better at so I'm just waiting okay yeah
what do you think Andrew Tate has
evolved in the most we've covered Andrew
Tate a lot what are your what's your
opinion um I mean I think he's a a
person who is a strong voice he's a good
influence um I think he's also giving
advice uh through life experience you
know you kind of see him kind of change
perspectives and certain areas but that
comes with you know different
perspectives you know he was in a prison
cell like you don't know what goes
through your mind during those times and
maybe you value different things so I
can admire that he's firm in some things
but I can also admire like new
information as you may refer to um he
adjusts and and and shares his
experience I think that's also keeps
that authentic uh human uh person you
know it keeps them like a what's the
word I'm looking for um human humanism
keeping it real keep it I will say one
thing um I actually said this to
sneo over a year ago when he came on the
podcast I said whatever beliefs you have
now just be prepared for things to
evolve sneo was I think 24 25 time as
you get older I think your 26 your
birthday is coming up in November I want
to say happy birthday going to be
27th uh this is in general it's not even
directed towards you in general your
beliefs should evolve meaning they could
get more uh you could double down on
your beliefs even more no I actually
firmly believe this and I'm going way
deeper on it or it's like you know what
I was kind of wrong about that let me
evolve a little bit let me but the whole
purpose of life is improving involving
reflecting maybe saying you know what I
could have done that better you know
given a second chance I would do this so
I think you you are going to evolve at
some point at some point you're going to
want to be a mother and a wife and you
know things might change I'm not saying
that you need to even name that now but
I don't think evolving is a bad thing I
think it's natural mhm
no yeah no I think opinions change over
time okay yeah um but no I think what
you're going to see if we're talking
about the marriage issue evolving on
that you're going to still see the
wealthy get married like that I I just
see it disappearing from the middle
class um it's more likely to disappear
from the middle class yeah regardless of
what I say to be honest um that I mean
that's what you're seeing um yeah that's
the numbers reflect richer men are
married at a higher rate so I think
you're going to see it disappear from
let want PR
up I will say one thing and I will say
just from anecdote not interviewing guys
rich men fa a bit better off in divorce
because um typically they have the
ability to you know yeah you you know a
lot of times wealthy men if they lose
their wealth they can make it back where
it's the the men that I see on the brink
of suicide that have like a tougher time
with it are the men that have worked the
same job 25 years have a pension and
their wife takes half they never recover